hello today we are reviewing donald the
green's new donald b green's new book a
creed
it's creed
sees uh i guess he likes the band as
many of you know donald green is a
popular social media influencer on the
meta platform he has a cool avatar
donald was raised in kentucky creed is a
sequel to a piece of breach
story is a good story plot i enjoyed the
plot narrative structure yeah the
narrative structure was good characters
there was a uh character named chaplin a
nice throwback to like the silent movies
the joker wasn't in this was he hold on
i read it you know hey yeah it's it's
jake thank you thank you so you were
gonna give me an advanced copy no i
didn't tell anyone that no i know you've
read the wheel of time it was a flipping
joke wait did you did you act did you
read the wheel of time what about knife
of dreams what the heck
[Music]
i had a good talk with um
i had a good talk with uh
donald green's lawyers they're not going
to delete my channel and creed is
available
probably in every store maybe not
vons or i don't think i can
record anymore